hi I'm Ryan hi I'm Marie and [ __ ] what
are you doing no we won't start over oh
no this is Ross right here matter we're
gonna keep it real for you there's no
retakes
this is reactions Maria doesn't like
being in front of the camera by the way
so I said we could smoke while we're
watching this trailer because we're
gonna watch makes you cool smoking makes
you cool this is the jail under be cool
I do this is the trailer for Sly Cooper
today okay cool yeah I've been trying to
get her to react with the trailer for me
forever
we're best friends we established this
today BFF all right let's get our Sly
Cooper on
this looks really cool this feels like a
video game - this would be badass like
yeah cool is it cool trailer it's like a
little for
I feel like now though I just an era
okay cool this point thing looks a
badass
in 2016 we gotta wait time [ __ ] oh
wait that long
caught team I might have to go back and
play I [ __ ] give away my playstation
do your PlayStation can't go back you
know there he made a crash bandicoot
movie I could get into that I could uh
when I was a kid I was really carefully
other gambling I always died in Crash
Bandicoot as a child well yeah I mean
well that's why you get a restart stare
phone we're gonna end this with an
awkward silence